let's jump into this first story
trump says he's made up his mind about
2024 big decision is timing of
announcement i love this the hill
reports they say former president trump
said he has made it made a decision
about running for the white house
well in my own mind i've already made
that decision so nothing factors in
anymore in my own mind i've already made
that decision
do uh he added do i go before or after
that will be my big decision the
interviewer then said midterms and he
said midterms
let people know i think a lot of people
would not even run if i did that because
if you look at the polls they don't even
register most of these people he said
and i think that you would actually have
a backlash against them if they ran
people want me to run
he could not have said
in any more clear terms he's running
short of outright saying i'm running
so trump 2024 i guess there we go and i
mean it is relatively early for a
president to make a bold statement like
this i know he didn't formally declare
but even with hillary the joke the meme
was she's running over and over again
because she really waited as long as
possible to even suggest she would run
what are the legal ramifications for
announcing for him you can't take money
from certain people or you can only take
a certain amount of money from certain
groups and people the the one oh it's
it's it's it's so um
honorable the way hillary clinton did it
right oh yeah because she made sure to
get those big fat goldman sachs
paychecks before she announced he was
running
yeah we know how that works those very
expensive speaking engagements that's
right
i feel like these laws really
incentivize people to kind of hedge and
hedge until like hillary clinton did she
got a bunch of money and then she
announced she was running it seems very
shady and it seems like we're making it
easier for them to do that and i don't
think we should make it easier for
politicians to be dishonest call me
crazy so i love this from cnn it sure
sounds like donald trump is running in
2024 oh come on chris saliza just say
trump is running we all know sure does
but i'll tell you what really frustrates
me about this and what i think is
actually the bigger story is donald
trump's penchant for
giving people who despise him the scoop
why
why does he keep helping these people
this was a big deal his informal
announcement that he's decided he's
gonna run
and that he wants to announce soon and
people may drop out and he goes to
olivia nuzzy
i think it's new york magazine and the
first thing they do let me see if we can
uh
we'll pull up this story the whole first
paragraph is just disparaging trump and
smearing it with every possible negative
story imaginable better than this it's
incredible he's the guy who looked at
who did you look at jim acosta you are
fake news
and then when when it comes to one of
the biggest announcements does he go to
breitbart does he go to human events
does he go to post-millennial does he go
to crowder or tim cast or any
independent outlet
he goes to the people the first thing
they do
this whole paragraph i can try to read
it fast it's very long
all right here we go
here's the first paragraph of donald
trump's interview with new york magazine
donald trump was impeached twice lost at
2020 election by 7 million 52 770 votes
is entangled in investigations by
federal prosecutors of the capital
insurrection and over miss handling of
classified witness documents and
over-elected interference in the
district of columbia attorney general
over financial fraud of the presidential
inaugural committee and the manhattan
district of attorney over financial
fraud of the trump organization and the
new york state attorney general of a
financial trouble organization and the
western county district attorney over
financial fraud of the trump
organization and the fulton county
georgia district attorney over criminal
election interference in georgia and the
securities and exchange commission over
rules violation and plans take his
social media company public through spec
and the house select committee on
january 6 whose series are the runaway
tv readings in the summer yet on monday
july 11th he was in a fantastic mood
why would you give an interview to
someone who's gonna introduce you and
your ideas in that way you know i i
actually think that giving it to olivia
proves his uh priorities which which is
that you know he's he doesn't really
care to run for
america he cares to pick up where he
left off fighting with reporters and
getting attention yeah i think it's a
huge distraction
um
from what we really need from a
presidential candidate right now
it's unfortunate to see him doing this
right out the gate you know what this
says to me this says to me that donald
trump has learned nothing he's learned
nothing he always wanted the media to be
his friend he wanted them to be on his
side even as he was calling them the
fake news he would still give all these
super combative interviews he has
learned nothing i see no way that he
would fire the people who need to be
fired that's a good point yeah i don't
think he's going to make any changes if
he does run again even if he does wait i
i can't believe he went to
new york mag for the ridiculous it's
it's absolutely bonkers well maybe for
the real announcement he'll he'll do it
with uh with an ally maybe maybe is
there any way to go it doesn't have to
be an ally has to be somebody who's just
going to
give you the news you know
is there any way to grab analytics on
this article that he that was written
about his
announcement that he's considering
announcing announcing for president uh
because he could have come out if he did
it on a show like this he'd have 1.6
million views overnight and it would be
his face and his voice which is what
gets you elected not text
except in biden's case apparently
yeah well he resisted going to any
alternative platforms for the longest
time until he had his own and he's clear
very clearly resisting yeah he went to
this lady holy crap take a look at this
from ground.news bias fact check olivia
nuzzy interacts 92 percent of the news
she interacts with interacts with is
left leaning look at that tiny little
morsel of right wing in there which is
probably like four percent or something
and donald trump decided that he's going
to go to the people who smear him who
defame him who attacked him who propped
up the lies who lied about kyle
rittenhouse who lie about just who who
lied in defense of justice millet who
lie about him and then first chance they
get when he sits down with this woman is
she opens the entire paragraph smearing
him in every imaginable way because i
want to make sure this point is clear
just because
people who hate trump are trying to dig
up dirt on him opposition research or
investigate him doesn't mean trump did
something wrong
we are innocent until proven guilty in
this country and people who are trying
to smear trump we get it they're going
after him but she makes it the entire
introduction i wish that he just went to
i mean
name any any independent journalist it
doesn't have to be a conservative he
could have just made a youtube video and
set data did a video
just him talking to the camera it would
have been spectacular i was going to ask
who is if you were to give an outlet
other than tim cast who do you think uh
who would have been a good site for him
together
joe rogan yeah but joe rogan won't have
him on which i don't even know if i
believe that like i don't i'm not sure
about that either it's uh given uh how
rogan's been talking lately i'm not sure
if i believe that but believe that he
wouldn't have him on
that he uh turned him down for that
reason like it just doesn't seem like
him yeah i heard that joe
i just maybe just got fed up with that i
didn't hear that he got fed up with him
imagine maybe he did and he's just like
i'm done with that guy i don't
understand why joe would not have
interviewed trump it doesn't make sense
i think he wanted to at some point he he
said he would host it i don't hate him
right but he said he would have a debate
between biden and trump before the 2020
election and that never never came to
fruition but i'll i'll
stress this point we made last time we
talked about this when joe rogan says i
won't have trump on because it would
help him think about what that means
joe
knows biden can't do it
and trump would be helped by it right
whether he intended to or not he was
outright saying donald trump would do
well and benefit from being on this show
joe biden wouldn't biden going on rogan
and like for two hours three hours right
three hours i don't think he could do
that
joe would cut him early he can't even be
trusted to walk around the white house
egg roll alone right yeah bite and can't
he has to have dress handling in there
you could no way you could handle rogan
we've been we've been having like this
inside joke about how people complain
about when they do rogan they they have
to go to the bathroom so bad when
they're done that like rogan has like he
loves it like he loves the fact that
these people just like can't go to the
bathroom and they're when they're
recording but but you can go to the
bathroom on joe's but they were just
picturing like him being like oh we're
not done yet we're not done yet he's
just playing like waterfalls in the
background
went to the bathroom
in his hallway i believe oh my gosh
sometimes they just do a cut and
sometimes if they just carry on or like
joe smoking or whatever they just carry
on yeah so i mean people bounce from
this show go to the bathroom you've got
to go to the if you've got to go to the
bathroom go to the bathroom you got to
go yeah i mean we're just chilling there
are times and places when not but on
podcasts
it will add
if joe biden was on with joe rogan
two scenarios would occur the first is
that he would probably be getting up to
go to the bathroom quite a lot yeah the
second is that he would be the one
person who doesn't need never went to go
to the bathroom yep because he's set he
just goes
thought that's where you were going but
i wasn't sure i'm great so yeah
could you imagine watching rogan with
biden and then it like joe says
something like but come on man like you
know joe rogan says come on you're
talking about
the the mass printing of money that's
got to have some kind of inflationary
effect and then it cuts to joe and
joseph's like
oh no
no what am i doing here buy it
one more minute his eyes would go like
really wide for a second
pops
i saw a video of uh of biden man he
looks he looks worse and people realize
poor guy
the israel are you talking about him
coming off the plane kind of disorder
what am i doing here it might have been
that one it was a he sniffs a little boy
oh no
i saw that
but he's just like
it was who was it who said he looks like
the dude from hannibal oh my god i don't
remember because that was last night
yeah
that's
dude biden does and uh
trump uh did did
this is funny we just mentioned the
other day
trump needs to announce asap
because it puts biden in the worst
possible position
if biden drops out
due to his health or whatever after
trump runs
you know or trump announces then he's
like oh joe biden ran away scared the
democrats know they're not going to win
it would look really really bad and a
big component to elections is many
people vote for whoever they think is
going to win it's a weird thing about
people in this country especially
so that's bad or what if joe bows out
due to
or the democrats pull him out like
either way if trump announces and then
biden is is out for for some reason
the democrats are going to lose
significant support if they have any at
all do you think that's still an issue
here with this polarizer climate as we
have right now that people are still
voting for who they think is going to
win
you know maybe maybe maybe some people
i'll tell you the crazy thing there was
an article in axios talking about the
realignment
about how uh the republican party has
become more uh
diverse racially diverse and more
working class and the democrats have
become whiter and wealthier that it's
for sure trump lost white white votes
that's the crazy thing
he gained votes in the black community
the latino community along the rio
grande valley and so the democrats are
becoming the elite white they're they're
the elite white liberals
so their concerns are not what regular
people are concerned with no i mean
just just looking at the big issues that
they're trying to talk about they're so
obsessed with abortion and
you know and and pronouns and uh and and
calling
well people the right pronoun and then
meanwhile
real americans are trying to get to work
they're trying to fill their tanks i
mean
it's it's so out of touch i wanna i
wanna i wanna play this clip for all you
guys
for those big fans joe biden i got a
clip for you steve guest says joe biden
tries to shake hands with nobody again
and he does and here's the video of joe
biden
yeah the idea was in the wrong setting
time darn it here we go here we go we
got it gotcha everybody here we go
thank you president herzog and president
okay we're gonna we're gonna do a
slow-motion play-by-play
here we have president joe biden at the
podium he goes to shake the hand of this
man i don't know who that guy is and he
turns to reach his hand out who's over
there and there's no one there here's
the best part wait you really got to see
this
he reaches his hand out to shake pauses
and then looks at his hand like he's
tripping look at that oh my gosh what
did you see that on he just points he's
like going this way but it's the
weirdest thing where he like he reaches
his hand out and then he just like looks
at it like what is this thing attached
to me by my body oh my gosh if it was
hunter it'd be because he'd been up for
three days at a time and he wasn't
watching things but like it really does
uh and speech repeat the line it's uh it
gets harder and harder to ignore um for
regular people and i do think that the
average ordinary citizen maybe the
reason trump has not like kept his uh
going the way that things are is because
he feels like any deviation from things
will mix up the momentum of letting them
screw up what they're doing never
interrupt your enemy yeah joe biden when
he ran he didn't actually run you know
he kept calling a lid yeah and when you
watch this video he reaches his arm out
he's not pointing he's reaching his arm
out open palm and then he just looks at
his hand look at that he's like he's
like staring at his hand no one here now
here's the best part the last time this
happened
politifact said president joe biden was
confused turned around and shook hands
with thin air after a speech false how
did they square that circle they said oh
he was just gesturing to the crowd it's
like dude he did it again
this is the game they play yeah it's
like joe biden could fall down and start
screaming and they would be like he was
auditioning for the movie actually
totally normal the first time he ever
said end of quote they were like he's
not reading the prompter wrong he's it
was part of the speech
most people say end of quote when
they're ending a quote then he says it
again
repeat the line
he goes end of quote repeat the line and
it's dude you read the instructions
it's luck man it's a run burgundy moment
last night i was praying for this man's
mental health just his health in general
as much as i understand that he's bad at
his job i want him to fail so let's just
harp on him until he's gone but a
sick-minded president can ruin the world
so we need
maybe not we need to support him in some
way acknowledging that he doesn't
shouldn't be the president ian
a sick-minded president could ruin the
world he's doing it
he is ruining the world right now he
gave a million barrels of our strategic
oil reserves he surrendered to the
taliban yeah come on come on man he gave
our oil to china hey jaina to sign a
pack
and then the media is fact checking me
being like tim pool's opinion on that
being a bad thing is wrong
dude when he bit his wife's hand during
the speech too
that was funny remember when he was in
the shower yeah you know that yo you see
that picture she's like she reaches out
and then he goes like
that's right it's amazing this is
i remember when he mixed up his sister
and his wife that was weird yeah that
was weird yeah we should have known oh
it's no big deal he just nibbled on his
wife's finger in a bizarre campaign
there's no trouble in paradise the
bidens are romantic and happy yeah well
to be fair you know to say joe biden
bites wife is a little bit over the top
but by him bites wife but i think what
you see with a story like this is that
he's just not cognizant of his
surroundings
like he's lost his filter yeah you don't
you don't do this
and then everyone was like oh it was
funny it was you know his wife and he's
not funny yeah it's not funny it's
terrifying it's not weird
it's so weird
look at this
what is this
what is this image somebody sent me that
picture today and they're like why does
this picture exist and i was like that
really happened her hand is cold
i was hungry come on man
i thought it was a snack
i don't know dude
you know butterfingers yeah well so look
look trump trump informally announces
he's running but this poll comes out the
new york times uh time sienna poll
saying that 44 to 41 biden wins
there's obviously other polls saying
that's complete bunk there's another
poll i was reading today that said trump
wins 43 to 41. it's gonna be too close i
just can't imagine
and this could be hubris that joe biden
could beat trump in a rematch
it's like it's one thing when when biden
shows up says i'm going to run against
trump
and then all the media does is say that
covet is trump's fault yeah and then
says nothing about joe biden jobiden
hides yeah so the only news story it was
crazy because we mentioned this back
during the campaign i was like if the
media only focuses on trump then there's
going to be nothing about biden so
people will be voting against trump and
that's that's what happened yeah so now
joe biden is known to people and they're
not happy with it joe biden's approval
rating in aggregate is lower today than
where trump's was at the same time as
presidency and here's the best part his
approval rating is lower today than
where trump's was after january 6.
wow yeah does he lose just on the
economy
biden yeah why what do you mean like is
that enough alone beyond the bizarre
behavior
you know i'd say yes normally but
democrats are
the party of the wealthy elites and
they're cultists they believe insane
things they're in a bubble they don't
know what's going on in the real world
they believe the cal written house lies
the covenant catholic lies they believed
jesse smilet right i don't look
imagine you're on a a sinking ship
and there's like a someone comes and
says i have a set of instructions to to
save the boat from sync and you're like
okay and the other guy walks up to you
and goes i think justice was telling the
truth and i'm the one who's in charge
you're going to be like okay we're
doomed right
like how are we how are we going to
effectively fix this thing if that guy
is the one who's supposed to be like we
have to argue with each other over how
to save this ship
yeah so on the question of the economy i
actually saw and this was very
unsettling to me because i've been
harping about these shootings that have
been happening in red states and then in
blue states with and without gun control
and i said i think that this is going to
mean the democrats pull alongside the
republicans over the economy i think
guns are going to become more important
the economy and sure enough it's showing
that this is bringing them up alongside
the republicans as november is coming up
just like i thought it would happen so i
don't know what's going to happen
obviously but the fact that they have so
well publicized these two different
attacks whether you have gun control or
not whether you have the armed good guy
or not whether you have red flag red
flag laws or not you still have the same
effect i think that this has been an
incredibly effective strategy for them
to push the concept of guns to the
forefront of the american public's mind
let me let me pull up this real quick
just to drive it home president trump
job approval from real clear politics
this is the aggregate of all polling
yeah i think they go back what is it
like 10 polls or something uh check this
out
after january 6 donald trump's approval
rating was 39 39.3 percent it tanked
joe biden today is
38.6
oh my gosh wow that's remarkable it
wasn't an event that caused it either
it's just like it's just like slowed
down yeah it wasn't like a sharp dip
like it was with trump yeah yeah with
trump like all of a sudden everybody
heard this thing and they were like yeah
if a war gets started it spikes up if if
some dumb crap happens it spikes down
but this is just an example of a
president that's presiding over a
sinking ship like ian he's thinking do
you know
why
joe biden's approval dipped and his
disapproval spiked above his approval
rating
do you know what was the catalyst for it
i bet i know uh
i
wait which point oh right there tell me
is that understand
that's right he's submitted to the
taliban that's a big dip too after uh
joe biden surrendered
failed and i mean
this is this is one of the reasons i
believe that joe biden is not the puppet
people think he is he's more like i'm
not saying he's in charge i'm saying he
sort of is and everyone's kind of
confused but he's still being given
instruction by his aides we're trying to
help him right like you can have
you can hire someone to help you who
tells you what to do but you're still in
charge right
afghanistan
was such a complete and total failure
that made no sense
made absolutely zero sense
joe biden was was
in the situation room probably going oh
a good airport and then they like
evacuate bagram the american people saw
that and after the abandoning of our
troops the the was it 13
brave men and women who were killed
outside the airport joe biden's approval
rating has never come back
that's it that's a good point that was
it that was it for me i mean
images of the plane of the
yeah
that was that you got to talk to tim
kennedy about what he saw but but people
just need to realize this when ian
who has never been like a big trump guy
is like joe biden surrendered
afghanistan like is that animated about
it
i think that's a good barometer for a
lot of people who aren't particularly
active in politics i believe we should
focus on this this job of the president
as the commander of the military that is
their number one job as the
commander-in-chief of the military and
if they don't have a military mind like
donald trump whatever he didn't know
that they were playing shell games on
him and lying to him about troop
movement i he
you know hindsight's always 20 20. i
don't know what if he could have done it
better probably could have done it but
listening to kurt schlichter last night
explain like what a president could do
to take control of his military command
it sounds not that complicated if you
know what to do but these guys didn't
know what to do trump didn't know what
to do biden didn't know what to do
but will trump really do it you know
like we mentioned just a moment ago
he comes to these far left extremist
journalists and he gives them the
interview not only are their outlets
dying and they don't get the traffic
they despise the man and will lie about
him and smear him and so that's why i'm
saying you don't even have to go to a
sympathetic reporter you just go to
independent media and then force the
establishment to cover what you the
scoop you gave to somebody else or like
you mentioned do a youtube video yes of
course off the record like off the
script just talk if you don't if you
watch it back and you don't like it make
a difference make a new video but then
upload like a candid normal video being
like hey guys
they've been thinking about it it's on
the horizon get ready it would be people
would be lit it would be so exciting for
people to see that and to see him
talking straight does he have his own
youtube channel
i don't know that would be the greatest
thing ever yeah if you just became a
youtuber if trump yeah
i i okay you know you would probably
delete him eventually content creator
donald trump likely but still it'll be
epic if like i don't i don't watch a lot
of youtube at all i would i would legit
be watching the trump channel every day
oh dude yeah 26 million views overnight
could you so you saw that post where he
roasted elon and he's like electric cars
that don't go far enough
driverless cars that crash rockets
imagine him actually saying it to the
camera it would just be the best then
elon makes a video really watch the
apprentice yes well okay so it's funny
you brought up the apprentice i was
when i got pregnant i got super obsessed
with the housewives and all the
housewives
have appeared on the princess and on the
apprentice and a ton of them have and i
wanted to go back and watch these
apprentices i cannot find them anywhere
i think that whichever i think it might
have been nbc i don't know that could be
wrong but i think they took everything
off air it's crazy anyways
he was hysterical yeah he was like a
comedian like thinking back to some of
the stuff that he said yes i don't agree
with you know some of the the way he
phrased things and how insulting he was
no it was not presidential but man he
could make me do your [ __ ] do you
remember when trump blamed the lights
for making him orange yeah
he's self-aware yeah and he's funny i
have been to so many trump rallies they
are stand-up comedy routines truly it
was like george carlin in a sense where
he's talking about mainstream political
news and issues and he was just joking
about everything and people are laughing
and clapping and i'm like this man knows
how to entertain and that's powerful
that's charisma yeah i mean he's funnier
than comedians because comedians are
trying so hard to be these culture
champions and everything now like
watching trump just do it it's so funny
only rosie o'donnell
it was just
it was just perfect timing he had an
answer right at the gate everyone
bursting laughing and uproarious
uproarious laughter so funny he was a
timing genius yes somebody said that
what he should have done is built his
own like oval office white house set and
then like i had a youtube channel after
he after he lost the election where he
just second guesses and pretends and
does all the stuff that they should do
instead and just uh and do that on
youtube he's making a parallel
presidency he's funny and he's
self-aware but he's not quite humble
enough to make fun of himself he won't
really do it enough i think if he really
made fun of himself then he'd get a lot
more people on his side i think you're
right like i think that like on one hand
it's the the lack of humility is what
makes him a capable not capable leader
but like you have to be strong to lead
in that sense but a lot of people don't
like the fact that you're very uh that
you don't have the ability to laugh at
yourself or you don't have the ability
to take a joke at your own expense but
trump does
it doesn't matter if people are in a
cult they're in a cult you know it's
like brandon strzok his story is really
really powerful
how he thought trump was all of these
things and then he watched a video that
proved everything he thought wrong and
it was physically painful for him but he
was able to break out of it right and
and now he's like one of the biggest
trump supporters i don't know as of
right now but he became one of them
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time